[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
veux
m'accompagner dans le
Mississippi, nous emmènerons l'
oiseau Dre Ste Dans la
rue River, c'est la
rue où
la lumière F peut se rencontrer dans tes terres, terre de
rêves, on ne sait jamais à quel point c'est agréable
semble que Mead
soit
oui, quelle heure est
libre pour
moi, je peux perdre
[Musique]
mon là pour
nous rencontrer de vieux amis à G [
Musique]
avoir B
Street
Street les
rues où l'obscurité m'éclaire dans
tes rêves on ne sait jamais à quel point
cela semble agréable à quel point  beaucoup signifie
être
oui à quelle heure
me libérer je peux
[Musique]
perdre
ma
rue
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bleu